cocaine there I know the movie that
sounds like it was conceived by a random
word generator but like pretty much
every crazy film cocaine bear was based
on a true story after I saw this movie I
ran to the local forest service ranger
station and dug through the archives to
find out what really happened in Georgia
in 1985 just kidding I Googled it but I
still discovered some super wild stuff
okay
so let's set the record straight yes in
1985 a black bear consumed 75 pounds of
pure cocaine and let me tell you that
coke was not diet the bear legit ate a
whopping 2 million dollars in drugs and
no the bear wasn't an avid party here
the drugs were dropped into the
Wilderness from an airplane it all goes
back to September 11 1985. a former
Kentucky narcotics officer turned drug
Smuggler was bringing cocaine into the
United States from Colombia his name was
Andrew C Thornton II a pretty loud name
for a guy trying to stay under the radar
anyway while flying a small aircraft
over the Georgia Wilderness he realized
the plane was dangerously over its
weight limit so what does he do simple
drop 40 packages of cocaine into the
forest below to pick up later he
actually tried to abandon the plane via
parachute which unfortunately resulted
in him ending up the way his cargo did
no not eaten by a bear but lost in the
Georgia Wilderness and as for the
cocaine well the rest is history when
officials found to the Bear's body and
took it in for an autopsy they
discovered that its stomach was packed
to the brim with the white powder now
how is this kind of thing even possible
like it literally blows my mind uh no
pun intended get this the bear was named
Pablo Escobar which isn't the only part
of this story that's a little too on the
nose sorry I'll stop with these
unbearable puns last one I promise like
I was saying Pablo Escobar can now be
found taxidermied and put on display at
a mall in Lexington Kentucky like talk
about a party Legend did you guys hear
they actually used a real bear to film
the action shots gotcha but this CGI is
pretty bare levable I'm sorry I just
can't help myself when a major Motion
Picture needs a computer-generated bear
on a drug Bender there's only one
company you can rely on to do the job
right the new zealand-based WETA FX
company these guys are CGI Legends
they've worked on tons of films
including both the avatars Planet of the
Apes and Lord of the Rings which makes
sense because WETA FX is literally owned
by Peter Jackson guys by the way if
you've ever wanted more awesome behind
the scenes info on all your favorite
movies subscribe to the things please
there's always lots of Awesome movie
trivia being posted like all the time
anyway I'm glad the bear was entirely
CGI because having a real bear on set
for this would be total chaos also worth
mentioning here that no bears were
harmed in the making of This film a
large portion of the film's 35 million
budget was actually spent on their CGI
which makes sense considering the bear
is literally the main character of the
movie and it's not that expensive to
film in forests and though you'd think
the bear might be an obvious antagonist
Jimmy Warden the film screenwriter would
challenge you on that in an interview
with variety magazine he said the Bear's
not a bad guy in this movie what
happened is a product of circumstance
and everybody else's poor decisions wow
this movie actually deep and meaningful
that might be the biggest plot twist yet
so are you ready for another plot twist
believe it or not the director of
cocaine bear Elizabeth Banks had never
done cocaine she was a cocktail waitress
for years which according to an
interview with variety heavily deterred
her from ever partaking in illegal
substances and she was also a
self-proclaimed Goody Two-Shoes and look
at her now though this ain't her first
rodeo you might know Elizabeth Banks is
an actor acting in movies like The
Hunger Games love and mercy The Lego
Movie Wet Hot American Summer oh my God
this woman has been in a ton of movies
so it's so awesome to see an actor take
out see in the director's chair they
really know how to be a good director
because they've probably had to deal
with some pretty difficult directors as
a former actor that's Showbiz I guess so
Elizabeth made her directorial debut
with the Smash Hit Pitch Perfect 2 in
2015. even if you didn't like Pitch
Perfect you gotta admire Banks's
versatility as a director she also
directed Charlie's Angels in 2019 so
it's obvious she's got a knack for
provocative action films and speaking of
provocative she actually got her start
as an actor in a movie we've already
mentioned Wet Hot American Summer her
choice of the song Jane by Jefferson
Starship to be the opening track in
cocaine bear was actually a secret shout
out to that movie yeah Wet Hot American
Summer used the song Jane in its
soundtrack as well so like what an
awesome nod to the past so besides the
music of Jefferson's Starship there's
another unifying Trend to bank's work
poor in comedy are like two sides of the
same coin it's comedy Elizabeth Banks is
first and foremost a comedy director I
essentially make comedies and I put them
inside of other movies so like that's a
pretty big feat to make a comedy about a
wild bear on two million dollars of
cocaine this is a comedy inside of a
horror movie seems like Elizabeth Banks
has really cornered the market on this
kind of movie too and she had a
seriously talented cast to make her
movie dreams come to life but before I
talk about the cast I have to go on a
slight tangent about animals on drugs
everything in this movie has some basis
in reality which I'm proud of Elizabeth
Banks told this to variety magazine you
believe all these things could be
happening but it also tells you that it
is a supercharged bear so you're
probably wondering how would a bear on
cocaine even act well science may not
have the answer to that yet this isn't
the first time an animal has you know
partied dolphins have been observed
literally attacking pufferfish in hopes
that they'll release a neurotoxin that
can literally do a dolphin in in large
doses but in small doses it has more of
a narcotic effect so no humans aren't
the only creatures that do drugs but
cocaine bear is seriously on another
level although cocaine bear takes place
in Georgia it was actually shot in
County Wicklow Ireland also known as The
Garden of Ireland wow who would have
thought a horror movie could have such a
beautiful setting the cast and crew
didn't have much time to stop and smell
the flowers as they were working on a
fast timeline everything was filmed from
August 10th to October 11th leaving a
lot of the action to the post-production
team still they did a stellar job with a
cast of top-notch actors who were so
stoked to be making a movie like this
alright I'll talk about the cast soon
but before that I have to touch on
something more atmospheric we've talked
CGI filming locations and origin story
but like now let's talk about the music
for a second okay guys here's a little
throwback for all you gen xers out there
the score for cocaine bear was composed
by the former frontman of the band Devo
Mark mothersbaugh you can really hear
the Devo synth influence in the
soundtrack too
yeah
[Music]
this guy like invented weird music
sounds like a match made in heaven for
such a weird movie too he's also done
music for the classic Rugrats and a
couple of Wes Anderson movies among many
others Ray Liotta the infamous star of
Goodfellas which honestly could have
been considered the cocaine bear of the
1990s played a huge role in the film as
well his acting was top-notch as usual
playing the character Sid dentwood
unfortunately Leota passed away after
they finished filming in May 2022 and
this was the first of his movies to be
released posthumously Rey's Legacy will
always be remembered as one of the
greatest American actors always eager to
take on crazy and challenging roles like
he was a huge star in the 1990s playing
roles in Field of Dreams No Escape
forced entry and even Muppets in Space
he's always been able to fully commit as
an actor and take on some dangerous
characters and cocaine bear was clearly
no exception so is this the last we'll
see if cocaine bear on the Silver Screen
Jimmy Warden the screenwriter of cocaine
bear might have bigger plans according
to an interview with variety magazine
this is a story we can tell over and
over again I'd be excited to tell it
because there are some really good ideas
that we have for subsequent movies wow
who would have thought cocaine bear
would have any sort of lesson worth
repeating she has this unique feeling of
what is funny and what is true if only
Jimmy Warden could have written Mega
Shark vs Giant Octopus as some sort of
moral Parable I'm just kidding sometimes
crazy animal movies are just crazy
animal movies and that's what makes them
great what did you guys think of cocaine
mirror does it make you think twice
before hitting the road for some hashtag
van life adventures and be honest would
you want to see a sequel let us know in
the comments and don't forget to like
And subscribe to stay up to date on all
the things they actually made a movie
about a bear on cocaine and get this
it's based on a true story